all right why why what did I do
I didn't mean to do it whatever I did I
just do it oh I don't like you none Oh
Hitler Hitler blood Oh upside down oh oh
my god I'm gazing at it I'm pumping it
full of all my gays or doing my excuse
my you Inc steel yes please he's got me
by the balls engineering here's a signal
squad man this is a long tunnel to go to
get to the light at the end of the
tunnel hey hey squiggly Nikoli please
don't come back the glorious bright
shining light of death what am I
supposed to do about [ __ ] Oh
someone Kirsten I can do that too was it
all my Bergling how am I going straight
to hell should I deserve this okay we
I'm in Hell every time I wake up there
are roaches in my mouth I can't go and
everyone oh it's open okay I was close
enough
partial credit
oh hey how you doing King hell
cool excuse you and excuse me
why who did that where is it actually
like this whole thing is still [ __ ]
with me all right well I'm dead
oh no I'm live Oh get my neck brick
catchy tunes 14-page oh she's gonna be
in my bed just in my bed we're gonna
find my dad was fish you can't just do
that randomly hey hey now where did I
put now where did I put my car keys
pretty sure that ain't something that's
supposed to happen so let's add you see
when we [ __ ]
I hate you ha I'm not gonna do it